Hi there, it's Marianne here. Before we dive into today's episode, I want to quickly let you know about something exciting that's happening right now. If you've ever wondered how to create income that works for you, rather than constantly trading your time for money, then you'll love the Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge with my business mentor, Lisa Johnson. This challenge is designed to help you build sustainable income streams. And whether you're an aspiring psychologist, a mental health professional, or in a completely different field,
大家好，我是Marianne。在进入今天的话题之前，我想快速向大家介绍一件正在发生的令人兴奋的事情。如果你曾经想过如何创造为你工作的收入，而不是不断地用时间换金钱，那么你一定会喜欢我商业导师Lisa Johnson发起的“迈向经常性收入挑战”（Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge）。这个挑战旨在帮助你建立可持续的收入来源。无论你是立志成为心理学家、心理健康专业人士，还是身处完全不同的领域，
the principles can work for you. There are also wonderful prizes to be won directly by Lisa herself. And if you join the challenge by my link, you can be in with a chance of winning a one-to-one hours coaching with me, Dr. Marianne Trent. Do you want to know more? Of course you do. Head to my link tree, Dr. Marianne Trent, or check out my social media channels, or send me a quick DM and I'll get you all the details. Right, let's get on with today's episode. If you're looking to become a psychologist, then let this be your guide. episode. With Dr. Marianne Trent Hi, welcome along to the Aspiring Psychologist podcast.
这些原则都同样适用。此外，还有由Lisa本人直接提供的丰厚奖品。如果你通过我的链接加入挑战，你还有机会赢得与我——Marianne Trent博士一对一的辅导时间。想了解更多吗？当然想。前往我的Linktree页面“Dr. Marianne Trent”，或者查看我的社交媒体频道，或者给我发个私信，我会告诉你所有细节。好了，让我们开始今天的节目吧。如果你正寻求成为一名心理学家，那么让这成为你的指南。我是Marianne Trent博士，欢迎来到“有抱负的心理学家”播客。
I am Dr. Marianne Trent and I'm a qualified clinical psychologist wishing you the happiest of happy new years. Welcome to 2023. Does it look like you thought it would? And I guess, yeah, today, as I record this just before Christmas, this feels like a time of reflection for me. So I'm recording this on the 19th of December, and the 20th of December will be five years since my dad died and it always feels like a kind of nice chance to be able to reflect on what's come and gone in those five years. And of course I lost a great deal when I lost my dad, as you might well be aware if you've also lost a parent or someone significant to you.
我是Marianne Trent博士，一名合格的临床心理学家，祝大家新年快乐。欢迎来到2023年。这一年看起来和你想象的一样吗？我想，是的，今天我在圣诞节前录制这期节目时，对我来说这是一个反思的时刻。我是在12月19日录制的，而12月20日将是我父亲去世五周年纪念日，这总是一个回顾过去五年得失的好机会。当然，正如你可能知道的那样，如果你也失去过父母或对你很重要的人，失去父亲让我失去了很多。
But there have also been great things that have come since my dad died, and things that when you're in the middle of grief can feel tricky to even imagine that that would happen. I would never have imagined that I would become self-employed, let alone fully self-employed, which my dad was actually from when I was around 10 or 11, I think, until shortly before he died. He retired when he was 69. And so I would have liked to have had a chat with him about what being self-employed was like. And that's something that I won't ever get a chance to do. But I definitely got an understanding of what he was all about and what being self-employed meant to him and that he'd get his books out on a Sunday evening in the kitchen when it was quiet and he'd sort of go through them there whilst eating cheese and crackers. And yeah, I definitely got the idea that being self-employed is about working flexibly.
但自从父亲去世后，也发生了很多美好的事情，这些事情在深陷悲伤时甚至难以想象。我从未想过我会成为个体经营者，更不用说全职个体经营了。我父亲从我大约10或11岁时起，一直到他去世前不久，都是个体经营者。他在69岁时退休。所以我很想和他聊聊个体经营是什么感觉。这是我永远无法做到的事情。但我确实理解了他所做的一切，以及个体经营对他意味着什么。他会在周日晚上厨房安静的时候拿出账本，一边吃着奶酪饼干一边整理。是的，我确实明白了，个体经营就是关于灵活工作。
What have you achieved in the last year? What would you like to see yourself achieve in the next year? This has been prompted for me today because I had my yearly email sent to me from me. So it's something I set up via a website called Future Me and there will be details in the show notes of how you can find that. If you google Future Me you should find it and basically you can write yourself a little letter that will be emailed out to you at a specific time and date and so I forget about it every year. And then I see it in my emails that I've got an email from myself, future me. And it's really nice to be able to reflect on where you were last year. But then I've written my one for next year.
过去一年你取得了什么成就？你希望在明年看到自己取得什么成就？今天我之所以有此感触，是因为我收到了自己给自己发送的年度邮件。这是我通过一个叫“Future Me”的网站设置的，节目笔记中会有如何找到它的详细信息。如果你谷歌搜索“Future Me”，你应该能找到它。基本上，你可以给自己写一封小信，它会在特定的时间和日期发送给你。我每年都会忘记这件事，然后当我在邮件中看到这封来自未来的我发给自己的邮件时，回顾去年的自己真的感觉很好。我已经写好了明年的那封。
So it will arrive with me on the 19th of December 2023. So it's got my hopes, it's got my dreams, it's got a bit of a recap about where I've been this year, because we can so easily forget. So is that something you could think about doing? And if you did, what would be in it? You know would you celebrate things that have happened this year? Would you you know commiserate and be sad and be compassionate to yourself for things that have happened this year or that haven't happened this year? We all still lost a great deal from Covid even if people we know didn't die from it. There were sacrifices to pay for many of us with things that didn't happen. Are you still wheeling from that? Are
所以它会在2023年12月19日送达。里面有我的希望、梦想，还有对我今年经历的回顾，因为我们太容易遗忘了。那么，这是你可以考虑做的事情吗？如果你做了，里面会写些什么？你知道，你会庆祝今年发生的事情吗？你会为今年发生或没发生的事情感到难过并对自己表示同情吗？即使我们认识的人没有因新冠而去世，我们所有人仍然因疫情失去了很多。对于我们许多人来说，有些事情没有发生，我们需要付出代价。你还在为此感到困扰吗？
the things that you would like to have be different next year? And given that you might well be an aspiring psychologist or working in mental health, there might be things that you'd like to achieve in your career next year. So if you are an aspiring psychologist, perhaps you'd like to imagine that you might be on a doctorate by this time next year. So your doctorate might have started in September, or you might have had some really useful experiences at interview, or you might be really feeling like you've gained the relevant skills and experience for you to be able to stand a much stronger chance. Maybe you're able to say to yourself, yes, I believe it's my time and I am ready for this next step this year in 2023 because I do honestly believe that is what I would have said to myself and probably was saying to myself but not perhaps quite as directly as that in 2007 when I was you
明年你希望有哪些不同？鉴于你可能是一位有抱负的心理学家或在心理健康领域工作，你可能希望在明年的职业生涯中取得一些成就。如果你是一位有抱负的心理学家，也许你希望想象一下到明年这个时候你已经在攻读博士学位了。所以你的博士课程可能在9月就开始了，或者你在面试中获得了一些非常有用的经验，或者你真的觉得你已经获得了相关的技能和经验，能够让自己有更大的机会。也许你能对自己说，是的，我相信是时候了，在2023年我准备好迈出这一步了，因为我真心相信这就是我在2007年时对自己说的话，当时我可能
know I guess I'd already submitted my form which was successful but I didn't know that yet but I did feel it I felt like hopeful I felt like I was in the right headspace and that I had the right experiences that I was able to draw and reflect on in a great way that would hopefully I just felt confident you know um and so that's been something that's been really lovely to nurture people with in the Aspiring Psychologist membership which is something which didn't exist this time last year. It was born on the 28th of February 2022 that's when we welcomed our first cohort of members in and it's been the loveliest membership to champion actually people say really lovely things about it so if you're thinking oh maybe 2023 might bring me
我想我已经提交了申请表，虽然当时还不知道结果，但我确实感觉到了。我感到充满希望，觉得自己的心态很正确，并且拥有了可以借鉴和反思的丰富经验，我感到很自信。所以，在“有抱负的心理学家”会员计划中培养大家是一件非常美妙的事情，而这个计划在去年这个时候还不存在。它诞生于2022年2月28日，那是我们迎来第一批成员的日子，它一直是一个最可爱的会员社区，实际上人们对它的评价非常好。所以如果你在想，也许2023年能带给我
more people that understand where I'm at maybe it might bring me you know more CBT teaching skills and formulation maybe it might increase my skills and understanding in a number of areas, you know, including cognitive analytic therapy, psychodynamic, motivational interviewing. You know, maybe there's reflective practice stuff that you'd like to increase your skills and confidence in. Then do on board or to the aspiring psychologist membership which you can get for 30 pounds a month and you can cancel any time so if you want to dive in for a month and see what it's like see whether it works for you then absolutely do that and you can watch stuff on replay if you don't want to watch it live or you can do both you can watch
更多理解我处境的人，也许它能带给我更多的CBT（认知行为疗法）教学技能和案例构思，也许它能提高我在多个领域的技能和理解，包括认知分析疗法、心理动力学、动机访谈。你知道，也许有一些反思性实践的内容是你想要提高技能和信心的。那么请加入“有抱负的心理学家”会员计划，每月只需30英镑，而且可以随时取消。所以如果你想尝试一个月看看它是否适合你，那就绝对可以这样做。如果你不想看直播，可以观看重播，或者两者兼顾，你可以观看
things live you can watch things on replay and there's your weekly chance to ask me any questions as well. So, yeah, I am at your beck and call. So do consider that. But in the last year, we also had the birth of the Aspiring Psychologist Collective book. And that, again, has been lovely. And hearing people say that they really like that, they like feeling validated and normalised in their experiences. And people are still saying lovely things about the Clinical Psychologist Collective too. So honestly, when I decided to leave Employed Life in April 2021, well, I decided in January 2021. And then I had to wait out my notice period. So
直播，也可以观看重播，而且每周都有机会向我提问。所以，是的，我随时听候差遣。所以请考虑一下。但在过去的一年里，我们还诞生了《有抱负的心理学家集体》（Aspiring Psychologist Collective）这本书。这同样非常棒。听到人们说他们真的很喜欢它，喜欢在自己的经历中感到被认可和正常化，这感觉很好。人们也一直在对《临床心理学家集体》（Clinical Psychologist Collective）给予好评。所以老实说，当我在2021年4月决定离开受雇生活时——好吧，我是在2021年1月决定的，然后我不得不等待我的通知期结束——所以
when I decided, you know, it was two years ago, I decided, very almost, I couldn't have imagined that I'd be enjoying life this much, you know, and that's what I would like you to be thinking as well, this time next year, you know, I couldn't have imagined that it would feel this good to be thinking as well this time next year. You know, I couldn't have imagined that it would feel this good to be doing what I'm doing right now. And I've always enjoyed what I've done. It's not like I was having a horrid time. It's just that I was really liking the opportunity to be able to work flexibly and quickly and responsibly. So that was part of my decision to leave and to go all in because I wanted to be able to support you guys in new, different, creative ways that took more of my time as well. And of course, that allowed the podcast to be born as well. We have now celebrated, but we're about to celebrate as I record this, our one year anniversary.
当我决定的时候，那是两年前，我几乎无法想象我会如此享受生活。这就是我希望你在明年这个时候也能思考的事情。你知道，我无法想象做我现在正在做的事情会感觉这么好。我一直很享受我所做的事情。并不是说我过得很糟糕，只是我真的很喜欢能够灵活、快速和负责任地工作的机会。所以这也是我决定离开并全力以赴的一部分原因，因为我想以新的、不同的、创造性的方式支持你们，这也占用了我更多的时间。当然，这也促成了播客的诞生。我们现在已经庆祝了，或者说在我录制这期节目时即将庆祝，我们的一周年纪念日。
So as you're listening to this, this happened on the 24th of December. That was our one year anniversary. And you're listening to this this happened on the 24th of December that was our one year anniversary and it's just lovely I know I keep saying lovely but it is like you know working with you guys who are really eager and excited and hungry for information but grateful for information too you're just a really nice you know group of people to work with um so if you enjoy what I do as ever please do consider leaving me a review on apple podcasts or if you'd like to come on and do a testimonial for the podcast or any of the books then please do check out the details in the show notes let's take a quick break here and I'll be back on the other side. So come and take a look It's right here in this book It's the Clinical Psychologist Collective
所以当你听到这期节目时，这发生在12月24日。那是我们的一周年纪念日。我知道我一直在说“可爱”，但确实是这样，你知道，与你们这些非常渴望、兴奋、渴求信息但又对信息心存感激的人一起工作，你们真的是一群非常棒的人。所以如果你喜欢我所做的事情，请一如既往地考虑在Apple Podcasts上给我留下评论，或者如果你想来做客并为播客或任何书籍提供推荐，请查看节目笔记中的详细信息。让我们在这里休息一下，稍后回来。所以来看看吧，就在这本书里，它是《临床心理学家集体》
It's the Clinical Psychologist Collective book was a very helpful read and useful to step outside of the prep work for the DeclinSci application process to really consider if this is something you want to do and reflect on your personal journey. It is a very nice read and kept me company on train journeys. I do think Marianne's guidance through her podcast, compassionate Q&A sessions and this book has played a part in my successful application this year. Thank you. okey dokey welcome back so let's think about the practice of new a way to set your intentions. But let's not go too wild. Let's not change too many things at once. You know, you might want to pick one area of your life. So that
《临床心理学家集体》这本书是一本非常有帮助的读物，对于跳出临床心理学博士申请流程的准备工作，真正考虑这是否是你想要做的事情并反思你的个人旅程非常有用。这是一本非常好的书，在火车旅行中陪伴着我。我确实认为Marianne通过她的播客、富有同情心的问答环节以及这本书，在我今年的成功申请中发挥了作用。谢谢。好了，欢迎回来，让我们思考一下设定意图的新方法。但我们不要太疯狂。不要一次改变太多事情。你知道，你可能想选择生活中的一个领域。所以那
might be personal. It might be professional. It might be, you know, the way you nourish yourself or the way that you move your body. And maybe that's something that you can strive for. Just one area to begin with and really look at, you know, what we talk about this SMART goals. So specific, measurable, achievable, realistic and time focused. And the theory is if we can do things for 100 days, then it becomes a habit. Then it's something that we integrate into the way that we do things. So that might look like keeping a reflective journal every day or a few times a week, building that into your regular schedule. So for me, I tend to edit podcast episodes on Fridays and Mondays and record them then too. And I might, well, if I haven't done my email for the week, I might do that on a Sunday, usually laying down,
可能是个人的，也可能是职业的，可能是你滋养自己的方式，或者是你活动身体的方式。也许那是你可以努力的方向。先从一个领域开始，真正看看我们谈论的SMART目标。即具体的、可衡量的、可实现的、现实的和有时限的。理论上，如果我们能坚持做某事100天，它就会成为一种习惯。然后它就会融入到我们做事的方式中。所以这可能看起来像是每天或每周几次写反思日记，将其融入到你的日常安排中。对我来说，我倾向于在周五和周一编辑播客剧集，并在那时录制它们。如果我还没写完本周的邮件，我可能会在周日做，通常是躺着，
being quite comfortable, something that becomes predictable and repeatable so that it just slots into your life effortlessly. And that's what we're looking for here with any intentions or resolutions, things that you're choosing to do from a gestalt perspective, rather than feeling like you must or should or got to do. So I choose to create this podcast for you. And in doing so, I choose to sacrifice some of my time because I think that editing it well and doing all the show notes and the transcribing and things is worth it. I'm choosing to do that.
感觉很舒服，这变成了一种可预测和可重复的事情，这样它就能毫不费力地融入你的生活。这就是我们在任何意图或决议中寻找的东西，从格式塔的角度来看，是你选择去做的事情，而不是觉得你必须、应该或不得不去做。所以我选择为你创作这个播客。在这样做的时候，我选择牺牲我的一些时间，因为我认为把它编辑好，做所有的节目笔记、转录等工作是值得的。我选择这样做。
And therefore, it doesn't feel like I've got to do that. And sometimes just that small shift in the way that you think about things from got to to choose to can be really transformational for you and so yeah what could you choose to do in 2023 that might enhance your life or an area of your life and once you've got your hundred days under your belt, then you might like to think about a new intention, rather than cramming it all in at once. Because if we suddenly overwhelm ourselves with, you know, I'm going to get healthy, I'm going to eat really well, I'm going to exercise every day, I'm going to, you know, get the world's best job, I'm going to
因此，它感觉不像是我不得不做的事情。有时，仅仅是这种将思维方式从“不得不”转变为“选择去做”的微小转变，就能为你带来真正的变革。所以，是的，在2023年你可以选择做什么来提升你的生活或生活中的某个领域？一旦你坚持了100天，你可能就会想考虑一个新的意图，而不是一次性塞进太多东西。因为如果我们突然让自己不知所措，比如“我要变得健康”、“我要吃得很好”、“我要每天锻炼”、“我要找到世界上最好的工作”、“我要
have the world's best relationship, I'm going to, you know, get the world's best job, I'm going to have the world's best relationship, I'm going to, you know, do all this published research. There's only so many hours in the day, and it's going to probably lead to overwhelm and burnout, which might then take a dip on your self-esteem. So let's be kind and compassionate to ourselves. Let's be realistic. Let's pick one area. So if you wanted to look into getting some research experience or getting yourself published as a researcher, then what can you do to make that achievable? How can you break that down into smart goals? So yeah, have a think about what you'd like your life to look like next year and just take some moments to plan that out. Maybe think about writing that letter to yourself as an email on future me.
拥有世界上最好的关系”、“我要做所有这些已发表的研究”。一天的时间只有那么多，这可能会导致不知所措和倦怠，这可能会打击你的自尊心。所以让我们对自己友善和富有同情心。让我们现实一点。让我们选择一个领域。所以如果你想研究如何获得一些研究经验或作为研究人员发表文章，那么你能做些什么让它变得可实现呢？你如何将其分解为SMART目标？所以，思考一下你希望明年生活是什么样子，并花点时间规划一下。也许考虑在“Future Me”上给自己写一封邮件。
And yeah, just see where you get to and where you'd like to get to by this time next year. It has been my absolute pleasure to bring all of this content to you over this last year, all of 2022, which has just been wonderful. Thank you so much for being part of my world. And please do stay in it in 2023. If you've got any special requests for podcast episodes, or if you'd like to come along and discuss something pertinent to you that might appeal to the audience, please do get in contact by going to the podcast page of my website. And then there's a little form on there. So it's www.goodthinkingpsychology.co.uk forward slash podcast. You can also record testimonials for me on there. And I should also let you know that the other day I changed my Facebook business page to Dr. Marianne Trent.
是的，看看你到了哪里，以及到明年这个时候你想达到什么目标。在过去的一年里，也就是整个2022年，能把所有这些内容带给你们，我感到非常荣幸，这真是太棒了。非常感谢你们成为我世界的一部分。请在2023年继续留在这里。如果你对播客剧集有任何特殊要求，或者如果你想来讨论一些对你来说很重要且可能吸引听众的话题，请通过我的网站播客页面与我联系。上面有一个小表格。网址是www.goodthinkingpsychology.co.uk/podcast。你也可以在上面为我录制推荐感言。我还应该告诉你，前几天我把我的Facebook商业页面改成了Dr. Marianne Trent。
So now you can find all of me on all of my socials as Dr. Marianne Trent. Everything is consistent. Isn't that marvelous? So, yeah, come and follow me in all those places. Just look for Dr. Marianne Trent and you will find me and connect with me and it will be lovely to do so. I love to celebrate your wins. So please do connect with me and follow with me on LinkedIn and Instagram as that's where I see most of you and your wins. I'm on YouTube, Twitter, TikTok, Facebook, Instagram, LinkedIn. I think that's it. I think that's it. That's enough, isn't it? That's
所以现在你可以在我所有的社交媒体上找到我，名字都是Dr. Marianne Trent。一切都很一致。这不是很棒吗？所以，来关注我吧。只要搜索Dr. Marianne Trent，你就能找到我并与我联系，这将是一件美妙的事情。我喜欢庆祝你们的胜利。所以请务必在LinkedIn和Instagram上与我联系并关注我，因为我在那里看到你们大多数人和你们的胜利。我在YouTube、Twitter、TikTok、Facebook、Instagram、LinkedIn上都有账号。我想就是这些了。我想就是这些了。这足够了，不是吗？这
enough. I am also on Pinterest, but I'm not very good at Pinterest. But yeah, you could follow me on there if you wanted to. And I will maybe think about trying to become better on Pinterest in 2023. Do you like Pinterest? I find myself looking at nail designs on there recently. But other than that, yeah, I find it hard, hard to know what's going on. It's good for room design ideas and things, isn't it? But is it good for business? I don't know. Let me know.
足够了。我还在Pinterest上，但我不太擅长Pinterest。但如果你愿意，你可以在那里关注我。我可能会考虑在2023年努力提高在Pinterest上的表现。你喜欢Pinterest吗？我最近发现自己在上面看美甲设计。但除此之外，我很难知道上面在发生什么。它对房间设计创意之类的东西很有用，不是吗？但它对商业有帮助吗？我不知道。告诉我。
What do you think? So, yes, thank you so much for being part of my world. Do come along to the free Facebook group, which is the Aspiring Psychologist Community, brackets, free group. Stay warm this winter. Get the hot water bottles out. I've been really enjoying those. And, yes, stay safe. Look after yourself. Be kind and think about where you'd like to be by this time next year. Take care. My name's Yana and I'm a trainee psychological well-being practitioner. I read the Clinical Psychologist Collective book. I found it really interesting about all the different stories and how people got to become a clinical psychologist. It just amazed me how many different routes there
你怎么看？所以，是的，非常感谢你们成为我世界的一部分。欢迎加入免费的Facebook群组，即“有抱负的心理学家社区”（Aspiring Psychologist Community，免费群组）。这个冬天注意保暖。把热水袋拿出来。我一直很喜欢用它们。是的，注意安全。照顾好自己。善待自己，思考一下到明年这个时候你希望自己在哪里。保重。我叫Yana，是一名心理健康实习从业者。我读了《临床心理学家集体》这本书。我发现关于所有不同的故事以及人们如何成为临床心理学家的内容非常有趣。这让我惊讶于有这么多不同的途径
are to get there and there's no perfect way to become one and this kind of filled me with confidence that no I'm not doing it wrong and put less pressure on myself. So if you're feeling a bit uneasy about becoming a clinical psychologist I'd definitely recommend this just to put yourself at ease and everything will be okay but trust me you will not put the book down once you start. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
可以达到目标，而且没有成为临床心理学家的完美方式。这让我充满了信心，不，我没有做错，也减轻了我的压力。所以如果你对成为临床心理学家感到有点不安，我绝对推荐这本书，它能让你安心，一切都会好起来的。但相信我，一旦你开始读，你就不会放下这本书。目前还没有关于本集的评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。